seems like the perfect moment to rethink
what we thought we knew about american
politics the way the country runs
in the laundry list of lies that we have
been force-fed for the past year
now is the moment because clearly we're
at an inflection point
last night if you were to sum it up in a
single phrase
we've had enough
there's a limit to which you can push
the american population before they
gently and politely push back through
democratic means and that's exactly what
we just saw it is now impossible to deny
that this country is in the middle of
some kind of political realignment and
the people who run our country did not
see it coming there are a lot of
examples here the obvious ones are not
so obvious to start with the latter in
texas last night republicans just
flipped an overwhelmingly hispanic
district one that went for joe biden by
14 points a year ago
14 points
because of course hispanic districts go
democrat because hispanics are democrats
right
well the republican in the district john
lujan won and he won by calling for the
one thing you're not allowed to call for
in an overwhelmingly hispanic district
border security
countries have borders everybody
understands that no matter what color
they are it turns out
meanwhile in a place that looks very
different from the southern parts of
texas minneapolis really the cradle of
anxious white liberalism the place that
defund the police first sounded like a
good idea in minneapolis voters
overwhelmingly rejected a measure
to defund their own police and get rid
of their police department turns out we
need police even in minneapolis that's
dawned on them and then in the state of
new jersey a truck driver who spent a
total of a hundred and fifty dollars on
his campaign is as of right now
beating the longtime president of the
new jersey state senate
and it's not mindlessly populist to
suggest he'll probably be better
actually
but the headline is the party that is
calling for firing truck drivers is
suddenly losing elections to truck
drivers and if that's not sweet
we don't know what the word means
meanwhile the governor of that state the
self-appointed king of new jersey the
finance goon phil murphy was of course
going to win his race by some massive
margin it's new jersey it's a machine
state joe biden won it by 16 points a
year ago
but that's not what happened not even
close instead phil murphy apparently
barely made it across the finish line
that's not even totally settled but as
of right now murphy's margin of victory
is less than one percent does he see
that as an endorsement of his policies
good job phil murphy
winning by less than one percent in new
jersey no he probably does that's how
deluded these people are
but here's the headline as you're
certainly aware by now and it's the
commonwealth of virginia it's glenn
younkin a man you had not heard of last
year ten months ago glenn younkin's name
recognition was two percent
if you didn't live next to glen younkin
you'd not heard of him
he ran against the former governor of
virginia who was governor just four
years ago one of the most famous people
in the democratic party for 30 years
bill clinton's best friend terry
mcauliffe
and he spanked him how do you do that
exactly well a lot of ways we're going
to talk about them tonight but here's
one interesting slice of the demographic
pie fox news has found that hispanics
voted for glenn younkin by a nine point
margin well that's odd because the
entire campaign a glimpse glenn junkin
was based he was a racist
it turns out normal people don't believe
that and they're sick of hearing it
in her victory speech the lieutenant
governor of virginia the woman who ran
with glenn younkin her name is winsome
sears made this point
this is the essential point
and it's clear that most americans very
clear tonight agree with it
this is not a racist country stop
telling us that it is stop lecturing us
improve our lives here she is
there are some who want to divide us and
we must not let that happen
they would like us to believe we are
back in 1963 when my father came
we can live where we want we can eat
where we want we own the water fountains
we have had a black president elected
not once but twice and here
i am living proof
well exactly nicely put nicely
illustrated
stop it democratic propaganda machine
nbc news the atlantic
the white house stop lying to us stop
picking the scab stop trying to divide
us by how we look
that was the core message that voters in
virginia sent last night
the question is will washington manage
to decipher what they have said and
unfortunately the odds of that are not
great
remember that on his final night of this
bitterly fought campaign terry mcauliffe
knows his way around politics brought in
someone called randy weingarten to speak
on his behalf on stage yes randy
weingarten a repulsive teachers union
hack from new york who has precisely no
interest in or connection to the voters
of virginia so what's the message of
that the message is really clear we
don't care about you at all
you play no role in this this is an
inside game
and of course they mean it they really
feel that way they think it's how they
win through coalitions you're not part
of it
you see this in everything they do
here's a senile president and a vp no
one likes deal with it america
in the case of virginia just six weeks
ago a low iq washington post columnist
called jennifer rubin assured us that an
endorsement from some has been
functionary in dan quayle's office from
the 1980s was going to make all the
difference for terry mcauliffe
the bill crystal endorsement will be big
reuben announced naturally on twitter
trust me
it's hard to believe that's real
but it's entirely real and it's exactly
why they lost last night hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else